Get ready to learn English with a Disney
Pixar classic: Up.
But quickly before we get into today's
lesson, I want to let you know that,
if you're new here, every week we make
new lessons like this one,
with your favorite movies, series
and more, so that you can
understand fast speaking natives,
without getting lost,
without missing the jokes,
and without subtitles.
Just like Razi, who says this is the
best way that she has found to understand
fast native speech. So if you want to be
able to do that too, it's really simple
hit that Subscribe button and the Bell
down below, so you don't miss any of our
new lessons.
Hey, let me just interrupt the lesson
really quick to ask you a question.
So, do you ever feel lost when you listen
to natives?
We don't pronounce everything like
you're expecting?
You miss words and it seems like in real
life we just speak so fast sometimes, right?
Well, how would you
like to be able to understand natives
confidently no matter how fast we speak?
Well we have a three-part Master Class
to teach you the Three Keys to being
able to understand
natives at any speed,
and you can sign up for FREE,
by clicking up here or down the
description below. We look forward to
meeting you inside.
Hey, if you're enjoying learning English
with Up, then be sure to check out this
playlist with all of our lessons
featuring different Disney movies
after you finish this video.